good morning Jones very nearly
Thanksgiving here in these United States
of America according to Greene family
tradition it's now time for me to tell
you what I'm thankful for which is a
wonderful brother who is a brilliant
writer an awesome bunch of people who
watch me make a fool out of myself on
YouTube an amazing family and a loving
wife who won't carry my dead weight
through all of Super Mario Brothers we
haven't my obligation to my mother who I
love and am thankful for has been
fulfilled I wanted to provide a service
for the google searching population of
the world at Google I typed in Y our
space and I'm going to answer the top
most searched-for question for every
single letter of our alphabet right now
starting now why our agency art well
first even positive stereotypes are
stereotypes so you should be ashamed of
yourself actually the theory on this
subject I think that generally
asian-american culture values smartness
and I think that our values as
individuals and as members of broader
culture has a huge effect on what sort
of people we end up becoming now why are
Barnes red and farmers we're treating
there would hundreds of years ago they
were doing with materials that they had
at hand what are the materials at the
head of hand was rust and rust is a
fungicide and put that in the paint and
it would prevent the wood from rot it
also turned the wood kind of a rusty red
brown color why are Cuban cigars illegal
50 years ago the communist Cuban
government decided that they owned all
of the land that Americans owned in Cuba
and so they just took America was off I
mean Cuba was like and then America was
like fine they were never gonna buy
anything new ever again why are Dinah
and Caroline fighting there I have no
idea who those people are but I'm just
gonna venture a guess that it's because
they're not imagining each other
complexly why are enzymes important
because every living thing on our planet
is basically just a series of chemical
reactions and those chemical reactions
are facilitated by that's right you
guessed it enzymes why our lemon goes
pink because the food that they eat is
pink why are grapes bad for dogs no one
knows why grapes are bad for dogs but
it's important to note that they are do
not give your dogs grapes and if they
eat a bunch of grapes take them to the
vet why are Jews liberals
really why are Kardashians famous
there's the thing about pain we decide
who's famous I've decided that they
aren't so the Kardashians aren't famous
Kardashians are famous there
infamous in fact why are leaves green
because they're packed full of
chlorophyll why are manhole covers round
the one because sewers are round in two
so that the manhole covers can't fall
into the sewer and three to give
douchebags an annoying and meaningless
question to ask in job interviews why
are noble gases unreactive because their
electron orbitals are filled duh
why are Oh shouldn't salty fresh water
falls on land and then as it runs down
rivers it picks up tiny amounts of salt
and then it gets to the oceans where it
evaporates up and the salt stays behind
fresh water comes up more sub gets
washed into the ocean over eons and eons
salt builds up in the ocean why are
plants green already did that well why
are q-tips called q-tips the Q stands
for quality why are Republicans stupid
oh come on people
why are significant figures important
because measurement is entirely useless
without knowledge of the precision at
which you are measuring why are they
called carpet baggers that's weird bring
back to science
why are unions bad who told you unions
were bad why are feigns blue aren't blue
and neither is deoxygenated blood
subcutaneous fat in our skin actually
blocks red light from escaping so you
only see the blue light that's coming
off of the veins huh why are we here
Oh Lord you're asking Google why our
yawns contagious no one has any idea
actually why are some bees so popular
well dear Googler in my opinion it's
because the myth of the zombie allows us
to do metaphorical battle with things
that we cannot battle in real life such
as disease and decay and violence and
the inevitable evacuation of ourselves
from our bodies John I will see you on
Monday Wednesday Friday